[Musique]
nous sommes le 14 mars 2017
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette édition du
7 8 les invités émission consacrée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département et cette émission est
exclusivement politique ce soir puisque
je reçois pascale poirot et les
candidats divers droite soutenu par le
parti chrétien-démocrate de jean
frédéric poisson dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
circonscription détenue aujourd'hui par
pascal thévenot le maire de vélizy et
puis en plateau également alex andreu
morlaix le président du rpf dans les
yvelines il s'engage sur la troisième
circonscription celle d'henri guaino
avec l'opt en lobant l'ambition
d'obtenir le soutien des républicains
mais ils l'assurent il se présentera
même sans cette investiture comme l'a
également annoncé philippe brillault le
maire du chesnay bonsoir à tous les deux
et bienvenue sur ce plateau avant à
d'évoquer les élections législatives un
mot tout de même de cet événement majeur
aujourd'hui il ya un candidat à la
présidentielle dorénavant officiellement
mis en examen françois fillon mis en
examen cet après-midi pour détournement
de fonds publics dans l' enquête sur les
emplois fictifs visant sa femme et ses
enfants je voudrais avoir votre réaction
à chacun d'entre vous sachant que le rpf
que vous représentez soutient françois
fillon encore et toujours
oui tout à fait et on continuera le
soutenir jusqu'au bout de l'élection
présidentielle et même après puisque
pour nous mise en examen ne veut pas
dire culpabilité
donc on laisse la justice faire son
travail elle le fera sûrement très bien
puisque je pense qu'on aboutira sur un
non-lieu et qu'on pourra enfin parler
des vrais sujets d'actualité sur cette
présidentielle est d'être tous ensemble
avec françois fillon
maintenant que c'est officiel cette mise
en examen ça va néanmoins est ce que ça
peut néanmoins freiné sa campagne encore
empêcher l empêché de décoller aussi
dans les sondages
je ne pense pas je pense qu'aujourd'hui
les gens sont habitués à ce ce battage
et cette espèce d'acharnement médiatique
contre lui politico judiciaire je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens ont une idée
de pour qui veulent voter
je ne pense pas qu'ils soient freinées
j'ai vu au trocadéro une population
vraiment enchanté de son candidat tous
derrière je vois des manifestations dans
les yvelines qui s'organise
quasiment tous les doutes ou les trois
jours donc pour moi j'allais dire la
campagne et les lancers lé ba plein et
ça m'étonnerait que notre candidat
perdre parce qu'après avoir votre
sentiment aussi vous qui êtes donc
candidat divers-droite législatives mais
soutenu par le parti chrétien démocrate
je pense que c'est un non événement
parce que il l'avait déjà annoncé
lui-même il ya une quinzaine de jours
bon et je pense que maintenant il faut
passer vite aux vrais sujets de fond on
est plus à tout ce qui est autour et qui
à mon avis m'intéresse vraiment plus les
français pour la présidentielle c'est
votre candidat françois fillon c'est le
candidat aujourd'hui que soutient le
parti chrétien démocrate et que je
soutiens aussi et puis advienne que
pourra
on va s'attarder maintenant à la
campagne des législatives campagne qui
s'accélère malgré tout à droite avec les
difficultés de françois fillon voit les
différentes formations qui se
positionnait les candidats se prononcer
aussi on va parler de vos candidatures
respectives dans chacune de vos
circonscriptions la 2e circonscription
tout d'abord avec vous pascale poirot 54
ans entrepreneur vous habitez voisins le
bretonneux depuis à 27 ans et vous êtes
candidat dans la 2e circonscription qui
couvre votre commune mais aussi manier
ou encore vélizy vous avez le soutien du
parti chrétien-démocrate vous ne
souhaitez pas spécialement le mettre en
avant ce que vous m'avez expliqué avant
cette émission
expliquez-moi pourquoi non c'est pas
tout à fait ça c'est que je pense que
avant tout je suis je veux être le
candidat de la société civile et d'une
grande droite de conviction
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là je
veux dire par là c'est que aujourd'hui
on enferme les gens dans des étiquettes
partisanes qui à mon avis peut-être
n'existeront plus dans deux mois et
qu'il est grand temps de revenir aux
idées qui font et qui sont bonnes pour
la france finalement et donc quand je
dis que le parti car diane roy ne me
soutient bien sûr mais le parti chrétien
démocrate a vocation à faire des
alliances avec un certain nombre de
mouvements et à la limite avec
l'ensemble des français qui se
retrouvent dans ses propositions et dans
les propositions qui portera avec
d'autres comme le rpf par exemple ou
comme parfois avec les républicains ou
avec le ciel ou avec le mpf ou avec
beaucoup d'autres et que même dans les
propositions du parti chrétien démocrate
on pourra peut-être parler plus tard et
en tout cas celle que je porterai au
niveau de la 2e circonscription même
incertaine d'électeurs de gauche peuvent
se retrouver notamment sur le volet
social puisque la gauche a abandonné le
volet social on va parler de
quelques-unes des propositions je vais
aussi précisé que vous êtes trésorier du
parti chrétien démocrate depuis le 11
mars dernier aux côtés de jean frédéric
poisson puisqu'il ya une une réélection
au sein du bureau national alors quels
sont les thèmes forts aujourd'hui dans
lesquels vous vous retrouvez vous au
parti chrétien-démocrate épouse allait
porter en tout cas ce que je vais porter
dans la circonscription c'est déjà
reconstruire la communauté nationale
parce que aujourd'hui j'entends beaucoup
parler est-ce qu'il faut passer la tva à
20% 21% à 22% est-ce qu'il faut qu'on
réduise la fonction publique de 200
mille deux cent cinquante on a
l'impression d'avoir des financiers qui
discutent de petites de mesures dans
lequel est derrière lequel il ya des
hommes et des femmes quand même mais
c'est important pour les we des causes
électeurs de savoir un peu ce qui les
attend en cas de victoire du candidat je
suis d'accord mais si vous voulez des
grandes réformes pour qu'elle puisse
cette mise en oeuvre il faut qu'elle
soit acceptée et pour qu'elle puisse
être acceptée vous pouvez pas les
présenter à une société qui complètement
fragmenté aujourd'hui les gens
n'arrivent plus à se parler
la france des villes et la france des
campagnes ne se parlent plus la france
des banlieues et la france des centres
villes ne se parlent plus il faut que
tous les français ensemble arrive à
retrouver un sentiment d'appartenir à
une communauté particulière
après c'est l'enjeu de la présidentielle
cette réunification ça devrait être
l'enjeu de la présidentielle mais on
n'en parle pas parce que encore une fois
les mesures on les changements même dans
une société
moi qui suis un chef d'entreprise dans
une société quand vous voulez imprimer
un changement
la première si la société est morcelé de
partout les gens ne vont pas l'accepter
et le changement ne se mettra pas en
oeuvre donc une des choses c'est comment
on reconstruit notre communauté
nationale
voilà c'est un certain nombre de thèmes
que je vais parler des mesures concrètes
pour le faire vous avez été aux
militants du côté de ce sens commun qui
est le mouvement politique issu de la
manif pour tous est un thème que vous
allez porter également dans votre
candidature
disons que ce thème de la famille
notamment exactement à reconstruire la
communauté nationale ça veut d'abord
dire de mon point de vue une éducation
nationale qui transmet les savoirs qui
transmet notre récit national et une
histoire que en m
et que on fait aimer à tous ceux qui
partagent le territoire français hélas à
partir de mort on peut construire
quelque chose ça peut être aussi ce que
un des thèmes forts qu'en tout cas je
vais essayer de porter et que porto six
ans comme d'ailleurs c'est une économie
au service de l'homme et non pas l'homme
au service de l'économie
je veux dire aujourd'hui dans les
entreprises le nombre de burn-out
explose dans nos campagnes
il ya deux agriculteurs par semaine qui
se suicide et tout le monde s'en fiche
donc voilà donc est ce qu on veut
continuer comme ça ou est-ce qu'il faut
quand même remettre à plat l'économie
voire dans la façon dont fonctionne
aujourd'hui ce qui est bon mais ce qu'il
faut vraiment corriger et la façon de le
faire pour que l'homme soit mieux
respectée au travail dans qu'ils aient
un logement décent qu'on lutte contre la
pauvreté qu'on protège la vie au niveau
de la conception et notamment lorsqu'une
femme effectivement souhaite garder son
enfant qu'elle ne peut pas le faire pour
des raisons sociales ou bien en fin de
vie lorsque effectivement on dit pour
les personnes âgées et commence à coûter
trop cher
donc si on pouvait les aider à mourir
dans la dignité
ce serait bien non il faut respecter
l'homme dans toutes ses dimensions et
que l'économie
ça nous empêche pas vous savez
d'exporter sa nous empêchera pas de
développer nos entreprises en respectant
mieux les hommes qui travaillent et les
hommes qui constituez les hommes et les
femmes qui constituent la société civile
aujourd'hui j'ai une question également
sur le candidat que vous allez affronter
le candidat sortant c'est pascal
thévenot qui était investi par les
républicains il est arrivé à ce poste il
ya un peu plus d'un an et demi après
la victoire de valérie pécresse à la
région qui a dû quitter son poste
quel regard vous portez sur votre
adversaire des républicains pascal
technique des lions pardon bon écoutez
je lui connais pas bien donc je ne vais
pas je vais pas pouvoir vous en dire
grand chose donc moi ce que ce que je
porte surtout c'est que aujourd'hui il
faut en revenir aux idées et aux
convictions et ne pas se sentir
prisonnier d'éventuels étiquettes
partisanes et pour cela il faut avoir
des compétences
j'estime aujourd'hui les avoirs
notamment par mon parcours professionnel
qui fait que je connais très bien les
collectivités locales
je connais très bien les acteurs plus
vite tout en ayant travaillé toujours
dans le privé etc
et puis il faut être disponible et donc
si je suis élue députée en juin prochain
ce sera mon seul mandat politique
et j'irai faire le tour de toutes les
communes de la circonscription au niveau
local
déjà pendant la campagne et après si je
suis élu pour bien sentir ce terrain là
en plus des sujets nationaux que je
porterai à l'assemblée nationale vous
ralliez de cumul des mandats il faut
savoir que normalement à partir du
prochain mandat un député ne pourra plus
être maire donc si pascal thévenot
éthérée lui devrait lui aussi choisir et
ce serait son son seul mandat en tout
cas oui mais revint il est vrai que moi
là juste pour préciser il ceci dit à
livrer cumul et il est fou cumul on
pourra en parler leur nom à l'occasion
d'en parler sans doute marché nous
organisons les différents débats et que
vous serez à face à pascal thévenot dans
les prochaines semaines pour débattre on
vous restez avec nous on quitte la 2e
circonscription passe à la troisième
avec vous alexandre morlaix vous
représentez le rpf rassemblement pour la
france mouvement gaulliste qui a été
initiée à la fin des années quarante
candidats donc aux législatives dans la
troisième circonscription et beaucoup de
candidats de droite 1 dans cette
troisième circonscription parce que
henri guaino qui n'a plus l'investiture
des républicains pourrait malgré tout se
présentait philippe brillault le maire
du chesnay aussi entend lui obtenir
l'investiture des républicains et puis
vous également que beaucoup de
candidatures à droite je dirais pas
autant que ça parce que aujourd'hui qui
dit droite faut aussi savoir quels
partis sont représentés à droite il ya
des personnes qui aujourd'hui ont
demandé des investitures auprès des
républicains pour se lancer dans la
campagne en cas de
l'obtention de ces investitures ils
n'iront pas au combat mois celle inverse
j'ai demandé aux républicains
ainsi qu'à lui dit et au parti
chrétien-démocrate l'investiture parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis investi et
soutenue par onze parties rassemblez
vous en êtes où se rassemblent de ce
rassemblement il est important parce que
je suis allé discuter avec un certain
nombre d'élus locaux donc j'ai déjà fait
mon tour des communes de la
circonscription je suis aussi allé voir
des responsables de partis politiques
locaux et puis nationaux et aujourd'hui
je suis investie par écologie bleus le
parti qui a été fondée par patrice hernu
et puis par pierre g le tronc coni je
suis investi aussi par le mouvement
humain animaux et nature qui a
représenté par jacques le boucher par
l'alliance écologique indépendante de
jean marc governatori que je rencontre à
nouveau ce soir pour discuter du
mouvement 100% donc le mouvement 100%
écologistes dont la 8 fait partie
également
francis lalanne est un des membres
éminents
j'ai également le soutien du hem unis
avec son responsable local monsieur
d'art d'ions puis également antoine
waechter et puis bah d'autres partis que
ce soit alternative démocrate que ce
soit le mouvement de la représentation
de la société civile le mpf
c'est à dire qu'avec tous les soutiens
que vous avez vous êtes élu en juin
prochain député de la 3e circonscription
vous siégiez ou dans le bloc de la
majorité ou l'opposition de droite en
tout cas dans un blues je serai dans un
bloc de droite quoi qu'il arrive ou du
centre en fonction effectivement d'un
lot de gros voilà crpf en tout cas parce
que vous allez investir trentaine de
candidats une trentaine de candidats
après le rpf peut se retrouver notamment
avec d'autres sensibilités politiques
ce n'est pas exclu comme le pertes le
parti chrétien démocrate mais également
d'autres partis comme les républicains
comme lui dei comme d'autres partis
du centre au jour d'aujourd'hui je ne
suis pas fermé comme on dit aujourd'hui
on fait de la politique pour rassembler
pour fédérer donc aujourd'hui je
travaillerai pour toutes les
sensibilités qui me représente
avec quel point de programme particulier
quel sera l'axé principal de cette
campagne qui commence presque dès à
présent j'en ai plusieurs déjà au niveau
écologique il faut préserver
j'allais dire notre patrimoine que nous
avons dans la troisième circonscription
on est jonchée de forêt on a aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de bâtiments qui sont
on va dire en fort besoin de ravalement
on a un esthétisme à suivre on a des
communes qui sont aussi des bordées de
permis de construire
on a aussi des problématiques comme vous
allez le présenter dans votre émission
sur des questions d'abattoirs donc 2
j'ai à dire de traitement de l'homme et
de l'humain tout ça c'est important d'y
faire attention
et puis je vais dire au niveau au niveau
politique j'avais dire le rassemblement
que je représente c'est effectivement
toutes les sensibilités de la droite du
centre des indépendants et de l'écologie
parce qu'aujourd'hui on lui on les
oublie et je préfère être un candidat
qui va porter plusieurs sensibilités qui
va représenter tous les besoins de
j'avais dire de la circonscription que
j'ai parce qu'on est quand même
énormément de communes en est la
circonscription avec le plus de communes
des yvelines un terreau agricole assez
important je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut représenter l'ensemble de la
circonscription et vous attendez le
résultat de cette investiture pour les
républicains d'ici la fin du mois
normalement on devrait en savoir un
petit peu plus mais sur qui sera désigné
dans cette troisième circonscription
merci à tous les deux je rappelle que
bien évidemment vous aurez le loisir de
développer vos différents programmes au
cours des différents débats que nous
organisons sur cette antenne dans les
prochaines semaines avec l'intégralité
des candidats qui se présentent merci
encore à vous deux c'est la fin du set 8
les invités replay sur notre site
internet nouvelle édition aux horaires
habituels dès demain
[Musique]